مرحبا لم تشهد السوشل ميديا في السعوديه
الخليج ومصر ضجه مشابهه لتلك الحبيبيها
الجزء الاول من مسلسل صالون الزهره مع
انطلاقه الجزء الثاني من العمل للفنانه
نادين نجيم يشاركها البطوله معتصم النهار
لان العمل لم ينتهي عرضه بعد حيث من
المفترض ان يصل المجموعه حلقات هذا الجزء
ال 10 ولذلك قد التقلب الحلقات المقبله
الامر لصالح العمل مفاجات عديده ظهرت في
هذا الجزء ابرزها الظهور المميز للفنانه
الكبيره سامي الجزائري واللي طال انتظارها
اما الاراء عن العمل ما بين من احبوا
وجدوا خفيفا مسليا وبين راهم محاوله اقل
استثمار نجاح الجزء الاول ومن يعتقد ان
الكوميدي والحوارات الكتاب
يكون هناك بعض الملاحظات على نص على شيء
بس احنا لازم ناخذ اعتبار انه هيدا لايت
كوميدي يعني هذا كوميدي خفيفي وبسيطه مش
مطلوب منه يكون مثل المسلسل التاريخي او
المسلسل الدرامي اللي بيحكيلي وقصه وفيها
احداث كبيره فلازم ناخذ من الاعتبار انه
هايدا ترفيه بسيط الحلو في نادين نجيم
الديكورات اضاءه معتصم النهار ممثلين
الهضم خفه الدم ال- ال- الصوره المبهره
حسب معلومات انه في تحضير
وهذا شيء اكيد بالاضافه لانه انا اقتراحت
على انه يكون في فيلم سنه كمان قد تكون
هناك ملاحظات على كل عمل مثل العمل بيتقدم
لكن من النهايه نسبه الاهتمام العام في
اقل قليلا بسبب الاهتمام بكاس العالم
كشف المنتج ممدوح شاهين تفاصيل مسلسل
الحاج اكسلانس بطوله الفنان محمد سعد
والمقرر ان يخوض به عروض رمضان القادم
طبعا هذا ياتي بعد غياب 8 سنوات
علا غانم هي البطله المرشحه انها تكون
امام محمد سعد خلال احداث العمل الا انها
لم توقع بعد لتصبح مشاركتها مؤكده محمد
سعد هو الوحيد اللي وقع على العمل من
شهرين حيث تم الانتهاء من كتابه 20 حلقه
بينما تبقى عشيره الحلقات محمد شفيق ورغم
اعلان شاهين لها العمل اكد انه لازانيا
ولم يوقع لانه مشغول بمنتاج مسلسل الحرب
والفنان
[موسيقى]
تحت تهديد السلاح من قائمه الافلام العشر
الاكثر اقبالا على الشباك السعودي واللي
تقدمت الساعه افلام اجنبيه هذا الاسبوع
بينما استطاع فيلم عربي واحد واخيرا دخول
القائمه بعد اسابيع من المحاوله وهو فيلم
هاشتاج جوزني الامير المصري
[موسيقى]
اكدت مصادر صحفيه مصريه لكواليس ان الجهه
المنتجه للعارضه المسرحي ساعه حظ للنجمه
من شلبي فقررت تاجيله لحين اشعار اخر حيث
كان من المفترض افتتاح العرض خلال الشهر
المقبل وذلك ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياء كما
قامت الشركه بالغاء البروفات لجميع
الفنانين الحين تحديد موعد جديد لافتتاح
المسرحيه الجديد بالذكر ان المسرحيه اللي
هي ساعات حد كانت ستشهد عوده منه شلبي من
جديد لخشبه المسرح بعد فتره الغياب طويله
وطبعا ياتي كل ذلك في ظل الاستقبال
التحقيقات بشان مواد تم الاجتماع ممنوعه
ضبطت معاها بمطار القاهره الدولي في مصر
عائده من الخارج طبعا الا انها نفذ ذلك
مؤكده انها لا تعلم شيئا عنها هذه المواد
[موسيقى]
تنطلق اليوم فعاليات مهرجان البحر الاحمر
السينما ما يدولي في مدينه جده بحضور مياه
السينمائيين من كل مكان في العالم حيث
يشارك في هذه الدوره 131 فيلم بينهم سبعه
افلام سعوديه طويله اثنين منهم في
المسابقه الرسميه للمهرجان واحد وهو فيلم
الختام الرسمي المرجان يكرم هذا العام
الفنان الهندي شاروخان تقديرا لاسهامات
المتميزه في صناعه الافلام والفنانه
المصريه يسرا اللي هتاخذ جائزه اليسر
الفخريه الذهبيه في حي فازت الممثله
والكاتبه والمخرجه اللبنانيه الشهيره
الهندي رانبير كابور
افلام عربيه
الى علاقه
بالدول الخليج او العلاقه بالمملكه انا
سعيد في هذا الاختيارات لانه بتخلي
الانسان يكتشف كم ماشي او يرجع يراجع
اشياء كثير كثير مهم اللي عم تزكريه معك
حق انه الانسان بده يستمتع بيستمتع بافلام
جميله رومانسيه او اكثر
حالو من السؤال من خلال هذه الافلام
ويكتشف شيء كثير مهمه زيتيه
[موسيقى]